the United Kingdom uses the pound
sterling and up until the 1940s the
pound was the dominant international
currency yet when you look at many
former British colonies you'll notice
that they use dollars and not pounds now
obviously we can't go over every former
British colony and so the two will
discuss a Canada and Australia because
these two nations maintained good
relations with Britain up until their
independence and both made conscious
efforts to drop the pound so why exactly
did these former British colonies use
dollars instead of pounds Canada dropped
the British pound in 1841 and replaced
it with its own the Canadian pound was
worth slightly less than the British one
and it wasn't long before it was dropped
for the brand new Canadian dollar the
reason why Canada opted to do this was
twofold and the first was a simple case
of proximity its nearest neighbor was a
major economy in Canada did a great deal
of trade with them which was only ever
really going to increase and for them it
was a simple case of neighbors having a
similar currency the second reason was
that since its inception the dollar had
always been a decimal currency what that
means is that it's simple since there's
only 100 cents to the dollar the British
Pound was not a decimal currency and
work like this each pound was made up of
20 shillings which in turn was made up
of 12 pennies and a penny was comprised
of four farthings thus a single pound
was made up of 960 farthings or 240
pennies and the value of these sub units
was very volatile now it should be noted
that despite Canada dropping the pound
it was still the world's primary
international currency after Britain
became the first major nation to
withdraw from the gold standard in 1931
it created what was called the sterling
area this was where all of Britain's
colonies peg their currency to the pound
at a fixed exchange rate and this was
followed by the Ottawa system also
called the Imperial preference system
which protects on other nations that
used a different currency in any trade
that wasn't carried out in pounds Canada
wasn't a member of the sterling area
because obviously but it did become a
part of the Imperial preference system
so what about Australia adopting the
dollar
it didn't neighbor the United States so
what reason would it have for dropping
the pound discussions about adopting a
new currency didn't really begin until
after the Second World War Britain was
largely bankrupted by this and so
Australia's main trading partner was
buying less someone who was buying more
though was America and given that
membership of the Sterling area made
selling to them harder a decision had to
be made
such in the 1950s Australian Prime
Minister Sir Robert Menzies ordered a
review into whether or not Australia
should continue to use the pound and the
answer was no the reason being that
Britain share of the global economy was
shrinking and so punishing the
Australian economy by preferring them
over the rest of the planet didn't make
much sense and one final reason was that
of identity Australia along with other
former British colonies wish to distance
themselves from the old imperial
Metropole in 1966 Australia ditched the
pound and adopted its own dollar with a
hundred cents and so that's why ex
British colonies dropped the pound for
the dollar the lack of decimalisation
made the pound more prone to
fluctuations which affected ordinary
people there was also the acceptance
that the United States was now the
world's dominant economy and that using
$1.00 would make trade with them much
smoother I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching but thanks to
my patreon supporters whom you can see
on screen now and with an extra special
thanks to James Bissonnette Ike Danny
Maloney Colin Castleman Marvin Castle
Rob Waterhouse Aaron the white Jordan
long way Chris wicker Gustav Swan Gareth
Turner
Marcus Ozma Maggie packs Kowski David
Silverman spinning three plates
Spencer Lightfoot Lexi Schwinn Winston
k-word Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett the original cage Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappell
pashya 19 and Mo